[Music]
again you don't do the dirty work I'm a
soccer player this is a roaming gang of
affluent soccer players
okay well it's so in the very beginning
yeah in stages number one let's keep our
critical distance we don't want to get
into the zone yet here's where you want
to keep the distance directly and I
noticed in the past you have a very duck
like sloppy style like this it's okay
we've made fun of it in the past but in
this situation it's gonna help you
something they're left really hard
third grade pulley is up there so we're
good so okay we're gonna use your duck
slaps that you're like I don't call him
duck slaps but whatever he hurts your
lateral movement right and then just
keep him at bay keep moving and keep
them at bay
keep the zone between you don't let him
[Applause]
okay
that was good news you're surrounded I
used my surroundings I used the talkshow
desk
because when I am attacked it will be in
the studio ok ok so now the next level
we've done you did you've done your duck
slaps you could even add and kicks to
the legs if you want to back them up
right once he goes in for a big kill
then that's when you move in and isolate
the weapon away from his other hand
right so if you can come in after the
fact or you can beat them to the punch
and come in this way and I flew at the
weapon right so once the weapon is
isolated now you have a chance now you
can borrow go in to do a sweep right and
he's like very cool so let's try the
whole thing
oh that ok with the ducks left and then
when he goes in for the big strike
isolate that weapon highlight the weapon
ok go there you go
[Applause]
[Applause]
that looks gross
okay we got one minute left okay so
let's tie together reveal the curtains
please okay a public restroom
[Applause]
why we we're gonna use all my techniques
why are we doing this in a bathrooms the
most dangerous place to be in especially
the evening because there are no
security cameras there are no witnesses
the walls are thick there's only one
entrance one exit someone can see you
come in and you usually caught with your
pants down you being serious here
bathroom every danger so case we love
you I didn't you sit down we're gonna
put you in the most dangerous situation
here okay I'm at the magazine to read
you think it's just a magazine but if
you roll it up tightly right it really
what you do that for just to show you
the power tell me I'll understand what's
wrong yeah okay so you're gonna have to
figure that out use this as an extension
if we have to do your sloppy duck
techniques okay
[Applause]
[Applause]